Doug: Hello! My name is Doug, and the name of the request today is recorded. Goose sighting 2, and the slug is UOCI
Doug: dash. R. Gs dash 4.
Doug: And the technology configuration here today, we're running windows 11, of course, with jaws as the screen reader and Google Chrome as the browser.
Doug: The summary of the task today is to
Doug: click the start button on the homepage of the site and enter in fake information.
Doug: and then we'll be. We'll land on another page, where
Doug: you'll have a choice of editing your results or your your answer.
Doug: and we'll try to change the name of the goose to the correct one.
Doug: and then we'll submit our application. That'll be the end of the task. Okay, so I'll get back to the screen
Doug: and I'll get to the top. So I'm at the top of the screen. I'm just going to use my arrow keys and explorer safely skip the main content. Okay, so we have a skip domain content.
Doug: Same page, link, skip, domain content. So I'll just press. Let's test that link. Same page, link, skip the main content page at 3 regions, 2 adding some 7 links there for smart glance highlights on the stage heading level. One recorded news to service, the polling list of free item, full telephony, like people tell us what type of bullet on which you saw the end start now, but adding level one information, Ok, so it re it. The skip domain content works just fine.
Doug:  I'm just going to jump back to the top. We'll look at a couple of other links. Same page links. This is not a real government service, and it's for training purposes only.
Doug: Okay, this is not a. This is some boilerplate at the top. You have to create your own list of items, Linko link environment.
Doug: So we've got environment and countryside. Those links look, while later, much like biodiversity, wildlife and biodiversity main region heading level. One record sight. And there's our main region. Use the service to pull in list of free items. Bullet telephony like these bullet type bullet wings. You saw the goose. Listen, start now, Button.
Doug: and let's press our start now. Button
Page had one region, one setting, one link, same page, link, skip the main content main region, heading level one. Do you like these? Select? Yes, if you like, these questions. main region heading level. One thing like this.
Doug: So I'm just gonna use my arrow keys here. So like, I mean, like these.
yes, right open project.
Doug: And I can use my form controls. That's good. Now get radio button check one. So we have. Yes, checked the radio button project. These are radio buttons. These are well labeled. Continue button.
Doug: And then we have a continue button. I just so I use my form control to get to that which is basically the letter F, no.
Doug: the radio button project. Okay? So basically, we're asking one question at a time. Continue button. We'll press space on, continue button, activate, presenter, boop site and boop site and phase one region, one that one link there, one smart glance highlights on this page and same fade link, skip the main content main region level, one type of boost, boostholder. Flexible.
Doug: Okay? So
Doug: I just silence the speech. I'm going to use my error. Location. Stupid of exploration here.
heading level one. What type of goose did you see, goose goose, tell us what type of Foos it was. Edit placeholder, black Spurgeon Goose continue. But
Doug: okay, edit placeholder like, tell us what type of cousin was at its placeholder, Blacksburg fashion. Goose, main reason. Tell us what type of fuse was edit when Placeholder Blacksmberg's type of text. So we will type in some text here. It looks like there's text already here. I just want to make sure.
Doug: Okay, no, it looks empty. I'm just going to type in some text here.
Tell us what type of person? What is Microsoft?
Doug: Okay. we. We have some text.
Doug: We'll tab, continue button. We have a continue button.
When did you see the go statue of the goose site? And when did you see the go statue, the goose site and page has one region, one that in one link. There are one smart glance highlights on this page. When did you see a go? Statue site and same page link skip the main content main region groups like, when did you see the goose spending level? When did you see the goose? For example? 16, 4, 2017 data monetary red? Did New Zealand.
Doug: Okay? So we've got to put a date here, either. Edit month edit. Date. for example, 16, 4, 27, 8. Okay. Edit.
Doug: Let's go back. And they edit. The main reason went to zealous group. For example, 16, 4, 2017. They edit my hypothetical
Doug: alright. Let's go and type in a date here, so we will say
Doug: we will say 20,
Doug: and we'll tab 2 to the month. Then we'll say 0 2.
You read it when you type the text
Doug: 2, 0 2, 4. You read it. 24. Okay, so we have a date. Continue. But exactly. Presenter. we'll press space on. Continue check your answer, statue site and check your answer. Statue, site and page as one region, 3 edges and 4 links. There are free, smart glance highlights on this page. Check your answer to site and same page link the main content main region. Level one. Check your answers before sending your application. That in level 3 boost the fail. Definition. List of free items to its cycles. Link change 20, 2, slash, 24 link chances. Sending level 2. Now send your application. By submitting this notification. You are confirming that to the best of your knowledge, but details you are providing or direct what happens with my data. Button collapsed. Continue button, main region and 10.
Doug: Okay, let's look at this page page answers before sending your application, that in level one.
Doug: So I just did a shift number one to get back to level one which denotes the main content here, which is good. Heading. Level 3 with the tails. Definition. List of freedoms. Heading level, one. Check your answer before now we're skipping from a level one to a level 3. And this page I would expect just to go from 1 one to the 2
Doug: so level one to level 2.
Doug: Okay, so let's keep going. Definition list of freedoms. You like these. Yes.
type of poos that you saw, which is HAND, EBIS. C.
That's landed
Doug: change. I don't know what that's for. It says you like these, yes.
Doug: change change obiscule. So that's what that's for. I focus on so type of goose that I saw
Linkedin Gate
ace a NDET a, E,
Doug: and there's a but there's so does. There's a button or a link
Doug: that says, or a link that says change cake. I'm not sure why that says cake.
Doug: But let's see if it changes main reason list with 3 items, change fate, link, boot, or whose sighted link fake has one reason linked into one link boot, or whose sighted same fate linked the main content.
Tell us what type of land placeholder likes windows.
Doug: Okay? So now it seems like we're when I do change.
Doug: and we'll type in black.
Tell us, what type of goose was it like misspelled Spurman goose boost when missmelts were missed? I space, Miss id
Doug: are
for like for wind boosts.
Doug: Continue. Button exactly presenter. Okay? So now we'll I've
Doug: wonder if it was coming. When did you seek? So now it's asking me, when did I see it? When did you see the goosebumps? They had it back.
Doug: Okay, so we'll type in current page. They edit the main region press enter to get into form, smoke and jaws. 20, text 0, 2, edit and type a text, 2, 0 2, 4. Continue button to activate. Continue, check your answers check. So now we'll check our answers again. Check your answer before send in your application. Heading level one. I just pressed a Number one to jump to a domain content, which is a level which has a level one, heading, heading level. 3 details. Definition. List of freedoms
Doug: like this. Yes, Lincoln took us to its type of boosting saw like swerving goose. So there's some text that really could be relabeled, which indicate.
Doug: like the link, for to modify your answers is called change cake. And there's something about links. Answer is. change abyss. What? Whatever that change? HAMD, EISC UI,
Doug: BISC. UIS. Jeans biscuits. Yes. I'm not sure exactly what that's for.
Doug: Link. Answer this type of goose that you saw. I guess you can change the above from a yes to a no, or a no to a yes, whatever way you have it, you can change your answers there like for Wind goose link, change gate. They do saw the goose with these left 0 goose, like Link chance they do saw the goose.
Doug: Now that
Doug: so this text for this label change date. You saw the goose that that it looks like that's ran together
Doug: a, a, NEDE, a, EA. Oh, change the okay. So the change and the da need to be separated
in that label. Listen, heading level 2. Now send your application. By submitting this notification. You are confirming that to the best of your knowledge that the failed you are providing are direct.
Doug: What happens with my data button collapses? So we have a collapse button here. What happens with my data? I'm just going to expand that to make sure that works nothing that just doesn't actually do it like anything. You'll have to store your own boot records. Unfortunately, main reason, nothing. Batch doesn't actually do it like anything. You'll have to store your own boots records. Unfortunately.
Doug: okay, continue. But we will continue button, activate presenter who recorded that record the site and who recorded that record whose sighting same page link, skip the main content page at one region, 2 headings and free links there, whose smart glance highlights on this page, who recorded that record of the sighting same page, link skip the main content. Main region editing level one who recorded the reference number HV. Free up! We'll receive your boost. Related information to get missing image descriptions open the context menu and legal traffic heading level to finish the accessibility exercise. If you think you found all the accessibility issues left there, including ones on the stage right there and take a look at the answer. Or if you want to have another check, go back to the start and click, record another site and exclaim, Main region and 10.
Doug: So explain link right to another website. Or, if you want to like, take a look at the answers. If you think you found volley access any level to finish the accessibility, exercise
the missing image description we received through saturated information HD. Your reference number heading level one was recorded.
Doug: Okay, so everything looks maybe
same page link, skip, the main content. Who's recorded that record site? Who's recorded that record of the same page. Link skip the main content. Main region.
Doug: heading level one is recorded. Your reference, number HD. Day, 21 will be a receiver, sat related to Edmund. Image descriptions open the context. Menu. Unlabeled traffic. Ok. We have an unlabeled image on this page, heading level 2. Finish the accessibility exercise.
Doug: We have a level 2 there. If you think you found volatile link, take a look at the answers, or if you want to have another check, go back to the serpent link right to another blue site.
6 Lane may reach an end.
Doug: Okay, my thoughts on this task. I can get through to task. Okay, there are some text that's sort of ran together like some of the labels on the
Doug: when you submit the answers page on on that page. When, before you submit the answers where you're given the opportunity to make some changes, the labels need to be relabeled.
Doug: One is called change cake. One is, and like to change the date just like change does ran together. And
Doug: so we have some text cleanup.
Doug:  one of the pages. I know that we're skipping from a level one to a level 3, and we should be skipping from a one to a 2,
Doug: and I think there were a couple of things I mentioned as well, and I can't quite remember what they are.
Doug: But I hope this presentation has helped again. My name is Doug, and thank you for watching today.